hi for those of you that don't know me
my name is jim clay wine and i'm a
technical fellow in office 365.
i'd like to thank you for giving up
about 30 minutes your busy day to listen
to me talk to you at microsoft research
summit 2021
about one of our most critical new
science and technology needs the need
for privacy preserving machine learning
to help set the stage here a little bit
let me describe the o365 business a
little
o365 is a set of applications and
corresponding cloud services
it includes popular applications like
word excel powerpoint outlook onenote
and their corresponding cloud services
the services that also support them
include things like sharepoint online
exchange online and onedrive
our mission is to make people get more
done
in their jobs and in their personal
lives this is pretty cool we make our
money by helping people be more
productive and to accomplish more of
whatever they want to accomplish
it's a big business with hundreds of
millions of users worldwide processing
billions of documents meetings and other
forms of communication each day
and storing exabytes of data on behalf
of tens of millions of businesses and
organizations
it's used by individuals and families
to communicate with family friends and
others school kids to learn charitable
organizations to conduct good work
small businesses to communicate and run
their businesses all the way up to the
leaders of multinational corporations
local and regional governments
national governments and even
international organizations and
governance bodies
even today helping people get more done
involves lots of ai and ml to help them
write better
in the form of spam spelling and grammar
checkers to block nuisance and malicious
communications with antivirus and
anti-spam
to help them be more effective
communicators with powerpoint designer
presentation coach
to help them find what they need through
search and relevance rank capabilities
and a host of others
having computers help people by doing
tasks that computers can do
frees up the people to do tasks
computers can't do
that's like be more creative find more
insights
invent new solutions to problems build
better relationships
and find more points of common interest
between people
that use of ai and ml will only continue
to grow
and we need to be able to continue to
deliver those ai and ml powered
productivity enhancements safely
that's where ppml comes in enabling us
to expand our use of ai and ml to help
people do more
but to do it without compromising their
privacy or the privacy of their data
so with that framing let's get started
i'm going to start with a little bit of
background that i hope isn't a surprise
to anyone
it starts with the very simple premise
that while we think the public internet
is gigantic
in real terms it is but it only contains
just a tiny fraction of the world's data
most of the world's data is not public
it's private and it's private because
the data controller has concerns about
other people knowing that data let's
talk about that concern for a little bit
and some of the data that motivates
now here's a list of a tiny subset of
the private data used in almost any
business
data that's typically created accessed
and stored in office 365.
based on what you know about ai and ml
today if you were a c-level executive
would you want this data from your
business used to train public models
now if you answered yes to that question
as an individual would you be equally
happy to have your chats with your
spouse your emails with your financial
planner or your attorney used in public
models or any other sensitive document
type that you have
you know it's really surprising how many
people especially those who are not
c-level execs say they would accept the
risk of a company's data being used to
train those types of models but as soon
as it's their data
that could get exposed through these
models
they suddenly get more cautious
now why do you think that is
well with
the the
well the consequences of a leak
could be bad it could be super bad
they include problems like identity
theft delisting from securities markets
mammoth lawsuits and in some cases maybe
even assassination attempts
in a risk-reward trade-off there's
nowhere near enough reward
for them to allow their data to be used
to train a public model
and to run that risk if
the model could leak the data
that phrase if the model can leak really
gets to the heart of the issue
well at least the heart of the issue we
can solve with science and technology
the other is legal
we'll talk to that in a moment
now given the nature of the data we host
those emails meetings customer lists
financial documents
and the confidential
confidentiality of that data
we can honestly tell customers
that our service is designed to not leak
data
outside of issues
that aren't in our control like someone
accessing the service with your
credentials or what happens when you
with your data once it leaves
our service
there are no known ways in which your
data can leak and if we find or learn of
any
there
are highest priority bugs and will
inform you
when that happens
it's simple
the message we tell is anything you give
us will keep safe it's forthright
we'll be honest with you and we'll tell
you there might be bugs and factors
outside of our control
we won't promise what we can't deliver
and it's transparent we'll inform you if
any data may have accidentally leaked
and above all it's honest and truthful
it's what we do it's who we are
we defend data entrusted to us it's who
our customers want and expect us to be
it's who legislators and regulators want
us to be
now we know
that materials that sorry we know that
models may leak data today and because
we know that we can't continue to make
that promise
the only promise we could make today is
the service isn't designed to leak data
except when your data is used to train
ml models
and that's a pretty feeble promise it's
a pretty weak promise
we want to be able to use ai and ml and
use customer data to train the aiml
and still make that strong promise that
your data will not leak
so the remediations available to us
today
are very simple
number one we don't use
data
that's private to
anybody we only use public data
the pros of that remediation is it's
totally safe
now the cons of that is it's super
limiting because as we started with
public data is tiny relative to the
amount that's available privately
our second option is to use a technology
like federated learning where we train a
public model and then create per user
models
from the public model so that
the model the data used by any given
model for any given user is only the
data that would otherwise be available
to that user again
that's totally safe but again
it's totally limiting because all we've
done is add that user's corpus which is
a really small percentage of the total
private data worldwide to the already
small
private public data so it doesn't really
add to the pool of training data we want
uh or number three we can use techniques
like differential privacy that decrease
the probability of a leak
and then let the users decide if they're
willing to accept the risk of the leak
you know today that's the most promising
approach but it requires us to be able
to understand
quantify and explain to a
non-technologist
like a lawyer legislator or regulator
what that level of risk is
if the amount of risk is low enough it
might not even merit letting them decide
the probability of a leak after all is
never really zero in the real world
so we're not really looking for absolute
zero we're just looking for something
close to it
now as we look at
the technical issues with model leakage
there's several factors some of them
like memorization properties of models
or model inversion attacks are
conceptually well understood so i won't
go into them
i will talk however briefly about a few
of them that aren't as well understood
the first of those is retention and
deletion policy retention's about
keeping data you need to keep for
example if you're being sued you'd need
to keep data relevant to the suit
for holding data a long time
ml's good
you don't have to worry about deleting
it
but it's twin deletion policy is a major
problem
uh
deletion policy is about deleting data
when it should be deleted when it's no
longer needed and shouldn't be retained
gdpr
and users who choose to exercise their
deletion data subject rights are an
example of deletion policy
that the eu mandates all technology
companies that sell and work in the eu
to meet
additionally contrary to popular opinion
most businesses don't want to hold on to
their data forever
data's not just an asset data is a
liability the longer you keep it the
worse that liability often becomes
businesses want to keep data as long as
necessary and no longer and they
establish deletion policies to do that
and they often have dedicated roles a
so-called records manager role
for people to define and to enforce that
data deletion policy
and the problem with data deletion
policies
is that if the contents
that are used to train the model
can be exposed through things like the
memorization property of models or model
inversion attacks
so that from the model you can create
some part you can recreate some part of
the training data then the model acts as
another copy of the data
and it exposes you to the risks of
having not deleted it it's like
retaining it forever if they can
recreate it with the memorization
property
and and that
is a major problem for businesses it's a
major problem for microsoft
if we don't honor european customers
gdpr delete
data subject right requests
then we're in violation of european law
and we can be subject to the fines
associated with that
and for a company like microsoft if they
levied the full
fines against us that they could
that would be a fine of 6.7 billion
dollars billion with a b
so we have to take deletion policy very
seriously
when data is deleted it must not be
reproducible or recreatable from ml
models
another issue that's not always
considered
is when everyone in the business isn't
allowed to see a piece of data when the
data is protected
by a
a accol by a permission
that'll that says no only certain people
can see it
there's a few great examples of that
things like pre-release financial
information
up until the point that it's publicly
released pre-release financial
information has to be kept strictly
secret
once it's released anybody in the
company can see it but before release
only a very small number of people in
the company can see it
things like attorney-client privileges
privileged communications also fit that
same pattern in order to continue to
enjoy the legal protection of inter
attorney-client privileged
communications
those communications have to be kept
confidential between the attorney and
the person seeking legal advice
if they could be leaked through some of
these
ml models and through these properties
of those models
then you risk losing that protection for
all of your privileged communication
which would be a disaster
laws like hipaa sec
regulations also address variations of
this need for confidentiality need for
privacy of data even if it's used in
training models none of them say
that you're that
the laws apply unless your data was used
to train an ml model then all bets are
off they say no regardless of how it's
used you must maintain these properties
so those are some but but
by no means all of the technology and
scientific concerns now i said there
were legal ones as well i'm not a lawyer
so i'm not really qualified to them
to talk to those issues
but at the root of many of them is that
ai and ml are relatively new
and
and there have not been
any legal challenges or substantive
legal challenges to what you're allowed
to do and how you're allowed to treat
data used in ai or ml models what's a
fair use of data and what's not
we can't protect we can't predict how
laws in court cases involving ml models
are going to progress but what we do
know
is the more we protect the privacy of
people's data the more we make sure that
models can't leak
and the model isn't a way to see the
data that was used to train the model
the lower the probability we're going to
be in violation of current or future
laws or regulations at all
so given that framing which is pretty
ominous assassination attempts loss of
listing in public markets mammoth
lawsuits
why on earth do we even want to consider
using private data
to train ml models
well the the
it's really about the data and it's
really about how much more data would be
available to train models and how much
better those models could get
if we were to
be able to use this private data to
train them
you know so how much data are we talking
about
how much if we solve this would we
unlock for training ai ml
and the answer is it's impossible to
know it's not public so
uh
so customers just don't publish how much
they have nobody publishes how much they
have and in most cases that's because
they don't even know
and it's growing so fast that even if
they told us today
it would be wrong tomorrow
what we can do is we can look at the
total corpus size for o 365 which is
private data just for the subset of the
world that's our customers and if we
compare it
to the total size of the bing index
which is public data for most of the
world
o 365 is several orders
bigger not factors order
three to four orders bigger depending on
what you count and that's just our
customers and just what they store in
o365
that's really strong
suggestive evidence that private data is
three to five orders bigger
and likely more than that than public
data that much additional training data
for ai and ml models is huge
if we just look at it graphically that's
saying the public training data which is
a big and powerful corpus just like
satya nadella is a big and powerful man
if we said the public data is about the
same size as saudi and adela the same
height
then the amount of data we would unlock
by doing this is the equivalent of
unlocking something at least as tall as
the world's tallest building the burj
khalifa in dubai
and
and it may be as tall as a piece of
string dropped from the height of the
international space station compared to
saudia that could unlock a lot of value
for our customers and for ai and ml
so what characteristics do we need ppml
privacy preserving machine learning to
need to have to be
successful well the first is obviously
it's got to maintain privacy that's
obvious ppml must be pp
of course by privacy we mean in the
strict sense of the word not the common
use sense of the word common use it
often means don't disclose directly or
indirectly the identity of the person
the date is about that's clearly
necessary but it's not sufficient
what we need using differential privacy
terminology
is a value of epsilon that approaches
epsilon now that's a bit of a geek pun
because it intermixes two different
definitions of epsilon
but uh but
what it really means is the probability
of sensitive data being revealed from
the model even with an infinite number
of invocations is very small approaching
zero
second it needs to be explainable
especially explainable to non-technical
audiences like users like business
leaders like lawyers legislators
regulators
and the popular press they've got to be
able to understand how and why it's safe
intuitive explanations consumable
explanations by that audience are
critical
now in many cases these will be
skeptical audiences if not actively
hostile audiences
they won't separate
pp privacy preserving from other issues
they have with ml
now obviously we can't
expect an explanation of why ppml is pp
to address all of their concerns
but our explanations need to fit
into
the
larger narrative about why
machine learning is good and virtuous
and safe for society to do
thirdly it needs to be provably privacy
preserving i said we've got to appeal
to those non-technical audiences but
those non-technical audiences often hire
highly technical advisors advisors who
share that skepticism or they share that
hostility so we need to be also able to
prove to those audiences
why this is privacy preserving
and finally it needs to be debuggable
by that i mean when it goes sideways and
it will go sideways and we discover
issues that made our ppml less pp than
we had hoped we've got to understand and
debug why we've got to learn how
pervasive the problem is learn its cause
is it malicious use by an attacker or a
blunder on our part was it an
implementation error or is it a
fundamental error
with the algorithms or science and then
going back to the previous two
requirements we've got to explain why
and we've got to be able
to prove it
to
achieve ppml is a lot of work
and collectively we need to invent a lot
of new science and new technology to
enable it but if we do
the payoff is huge
the value of ai and ml
even only trained on public data is
literally already changing the world
now if we add
three to five orders more data to that
what we could do with it almost boggles
the imagination that's why we've got to
work together
to guarantee
ml is privacy preserving
thank you for your time
you